vient alors la le pire est à venir je
vous le dis tout de suite parole à
l'interview expliqué à ma petite fille
on ne bouge pas pendant le qinghai
ça veut dire quoi annie aime les
sucettes à l'anis ça veut rien dire
allez si c'était l'année
voilà la grand-mère du son à la télé il
a dit non à faux ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que c'est une nymphe à un
niveau masculin
comment beau et grand mère
adamou c'est à dire une information à la
grand mère oui demain ma chérie ça veut
dire quoi d'amour précédemment sa vie
est un chanteur belge d'accord les
grands-mères comment humains joie à la
fin et je ne sais pas je ne sais pas du
tout et qu'on aime oui moi papa il a
fait un bisou sur la bouche à la baby
sitter
il a fait ce jour d'été
j'en ai déçu terrible à pau grand mère
et ma soeur elle à 10 ans recule et
c'est à dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est
qu'est ce qui vous prend par derrière le
du grand mère pourquoi chirac ma chérie
oui le président de la république il
paraît qu'il est convoqué chez le juge
il veut pas y aller pourquoi
et puis et puis johnny hallyday il a une
mercedes et puis toi tu n'as pas grand
mère pourquoi parce que là on a sept
français et grand mère oui papa il était
sur le lit il est monté sur le baby
sitter qui ça lui a fait mal à la vie
militaire n'a été pas de crier pourquoi
elle criait grand mère parce qu'ils se
rendent pas compte qu'ils aient qu'il
est lourd
je me réveille
oui pourquoi dieu là il a pas de femmes
non parce qu'ils n'aiment pas les femmes
ce que je